i have two items at the top
for all of you one is a readout of the
u.s india ceo forum that took place
this morning today the state department
hosted ceos from seven
u.s and six indian companies for a
session of the u.s india ceo forum
deputy secretary burns was pleased to
welcome to the state department
treasury secretary liu commerce
secretary pritzker
u.s trade representative mike froman and
deputy national security adviser
carol carolyn atkinson and their indian
counterparts
finance minister chinambaram
commerce minister sharma and deputy
chairman planning commission of india
montec
along with the ceo forum co-chairs ratan
tata of the tata group and david cody of
honeywell
u.s india bilateral trade is nearing 100
billion dollars
and ceo form today re reviewed our very
robust
public-private cooperation in support of
that and how we can further enhance
u.s india economic engagement including
how our governments can expand
opportunities
for our private sectors in trade
investment and innovation
the participants also enjoyed very
productive conversations
on new as well as ongoing collaborations
on water and energy efficiency
agricultural technology aviation
security health
and more underscoring the true depth and
breadth of the u.s
india partnership the uh the u.s india
ceo forum is a key element
in the broad u.s india economic
engagement following up on our
conversations
at the june 24th strategic dialogue and
my only other item
is that and you've seen this in the
press but just wanted to confirm for all
of you
that next week there will be a meeting
of the p5 plus one political directors
in brussels
on tuesday july 16th under secretary
wendy sherman
will be leading the u.s delegation as
you know they meet regularly
and this will be to discuss the way
forward
so with that uh let's get to just to
start you don't have any update on the
secretary's
schedule i do not i do not right now can
we start um
in russia with mr snowden i'm wondering
if since
he has now asked
the russians for asylum there has been
any contact
between this building and the russians
about your feelings about his
status well i can tell you i hadn't seen
or i don't have independent confirmation
i guess i should say about any request
he's made
i can tell you that we have been in
touch
of course with russian officials our
embassy in moscow
has been in direct contact on the ground
we are disappointed that russian
officials and agencies facilitated
this meeting today by allowing these
activists and representatives
into the moscow airport's transit zone
to meet with mr snowden
despite the government's declarations of
russians neutrality
with respect to mr snowden i'm sorry
you're disappointed that they let
someone into their own airport
i don't get it well that they
facilitated this event of course
why because this gave a forum
uh you don't think that he should have a
form has he he's forfeited his right to
freedom of speech as well well matt
mr snowden as we've talked about let me
just state this because i think it's
important
uh he's not a whistleblower he's not a
human rights activist
he's wanted on a series of uh serious
criminal charges
uh brought in the eastern eastern
district of virginia in the united
states okay i'm sorry but i didn't
realize people who were wanted on
charges forfeited their right to speak
to free speech i also didn't realize
that people who are not
whistleblowers or not human rights
activists as you
say he is not that they forfeited their
rights to speak so i don't understand
why you're disappointed with the
russians but neither
that leave that aside for a second the
group wikileaks put out a transcript i
guess essentially of mr what mr snowden
said at the airport
at the top of that transcript it
contained
it said that the human rights watch the
representative from human rights watch
researcher who went to this thing while
she was on her way to the airport got a
phone call
from the american ambassador asking her
to relay a message to mr snowden
that basically the message that you just
gave here that one he is not a
whistleblower and two that he's wanted
in the united states
is that correct uh it is not correct
uh first ambassador mcfaul did not call
any representative from human rights
watch an embassy officer
did call to explain our position
certainly that i just reiterated here
for all of you today
but at no point did this official or any
official
from the u.s government ask anyone to
convey a message to mr snowden did
anyone from the embassy call any of the
other
groups and representatives of groups
that were going to this meeting
well you understood we're going to this
meeting as as i'm sure would be
no surprise and as you know because we
even had a civil society event when the
secretary was there
we are in regular touch uh as we have
been today i don't have an
update on the exact list of calls though
for you but but you can say pretty
conclusively that
that this one call did happen and it
wasn't the ambassador
so were there others do you know we have
been in touch with attendees i don't
have any specifics for you
okay and the and you have made no secret
of the fact that any country
or government that gives mr snowden
asylum
or allows him to transit through that
that there would be
there would be some serious consequences
for grave consequences in their
relationship with the united states
have you made the same and presumably
that would apply to individuals who
would help him
stay help him avoid returning here to uh
face justice is that that's correct i'm
not sure what that exactly is
what i'm getting at is these groups
these human rights groups
that are respected human rights groups
which you yourself as well as previous
spokespeople have quoted from
relation to other situations
have taken aside in support of mr
snowden and i'm wondering if there are
any consequences
for them if they
if you if you if they aid in a bet mr
snowden and
staying away out of the reach of u.s
authorities well we
obviously don't think this was a proper
forum
or a proper elevation of him
um beyond that uh the way that i think
it's been asked but
also the way we've thought about it is
more about uh
governments and our relationships with
with them
uh and their aid or decisions to aid mr
snowden right but i guess the
the question is if you think this was an
inappropriate forum did you try to
dissuade these groups from going there
from attending yeah uh not that i'm
aware of matt
obviously they were invited to attend so
the calls were just a reminder of
your position but did you say to
human rights watch or amnesty
international that if you guys
help mr snowden or support him in some
way so that
to keep him from facing justice back in
the united states
that there would be consequences for
them i don't have any readouts of these
calls
our focus remains conveying to the
russian government the fact that they
have the ability
to help return mr snowden to the united
states did you tell them in the calls
that
you did not think that mr snowden should
have the opportunity to
express his view matt i don't have any
readout for these call of these calls
for you we did
we did convey the broad point that i've
made okay well then forget about what
you said
or what the embassy people said in these
specific phone calls
do you believe that mr snowden did
should not have had the opportunity to
express
his views at the airport in moscow today
oh well matt i think we broadly believe
in free speech as you know
but we cannot look at this as a i know
we like to
ask about sweeping scenarios in here but
no this is not sweeping at all this is
very specific related to one guy
in one place in one city one airport at
one time so i just
do you think that it was inappropriate
for mr snowden to speak publicly
do you i mean not that whether you're
disappointed in the russians do you
think that he should not have had the
opportunity to speak publicly
our focus matt is on how our concern
about how russian authorities clearly
helped
assist uh the ability of attendees to
participate in this
uh that is of concern to us our focus is
on
uh returning mr snowden to the united
states
uh beyond that i just don't have
anything wrong
i'm just i'm trying to get you are
saying that this essentially
it wasn't a press conference but it
might as well have been
and you don't think and you don't think
the russians should have uh
facilitated a propaganda platform for mr
propaganda platform okay so
this is to your mind something like them
bringing out a defected spy from the
cold war and putting on a platform
and having and and having him rail
against the united states is that
i'm not going to draw a comparisons
along those lines but let me say
a propaganda that mr snowden could
should return to the united states
to face these charges uh that where he
will he will be accorded a fair trial
that's where our focus is on the
platform or is this kind of putting in
train
a process for asylum because um last
week or two weeks ago the russians said
that they would consider his request for
asylum if mr snowden
um would stop leaking material about or
leaking information about u.s
surveillance programs now he wouldn't
not do that
before and he tried some other areas for
um asylum now
in this propaganda platform as you call
it
he said that he has decided to not to
leak any more information or he doesn't
have any more information but he's done
so are you concerned now that this is
him accepting conditions for russian
asylum
publicly as opposed to just you know
some kind of propaganda i mean is that
your real concern here that
these are these are the conditions for
asylum and now he's publicly meeting
them
uh our our concern here is that he's
been provided this opportunity
to speak in a propaganda platform
as i mentioned a few seconds ago that
russia
has played a role in facilitating this
that others have helped elevate it
but we still believe that russia uh has
the opportunity to do the right thing
and facilitate his return to the united
states i don't have any independent
knowledge
as would be no surprise of what he has
officially requested what has been
pretty public
okay but it's pretty public that russia
said that they would consider his
asylum petition if he said that if he
would
agree publicly to stop um leaking
information
now he's done that so is that propaganda
or is that publicly
agreeing to russia's conditions and
and kind of moving the asylum petition
along i'm just not going to make an
evaluation of what russia's conditions
are and whether
well you don't have to make an
evaluation they've said whether he meets
them that's not the point here the point
is
russia helped facilitate this they have
the ability
and the opportunity to do the right
thing and help return mr snowden to the
united states
it's not about beautiful conditions i
mean your concern
now is that this is that russia's by
facilitating i mean
are you really upset that this is
propaganda or are you really upset
that russia is moving closer to
accepting this guy's asylum
well we don't know that this is a step
that was taken today
obviously we continue to call for his
return
they have a role they can play and that
beyond that i'm not going to speculate
what they are
or aren't going to do what level of
seniority was the u.s official that
called
human rights watch uh i don't have an
exact position for you on that it was
not the ambassador though okay and
and uh how um how did the u.s get to
know about this visit was
that were you informed by the russians
or by human rights watching
we learned uh when it was public made
public uh just as many of
your organizations did that the
conversation
that the ambassador or whoever it was
the embassy had not with the human
rights people but with the russian
government
did you tell them that facilitating this
appearance by mr snowden was problematic
that you just
that you thought that they shouldn't do
it did you ask them not to do it
we made our concerns and our view on mr
snowden clear
no but uh specifically about giving him
this propaganda platform
i just i don't have any more to read out
for you from the private phone calls
matt just that there
we have this the russians please don't
do this we think he's a criminal and
needs to come back did you did
i mean did you ask and they and they
rejected the request
well matt we've been clear publicly
countless times
and we've consistently made the same
points privately today and any other day
right but did you say
that you would look negatively on them
providing him
on them providing him a quote-unquote
propaganda platform
i just don't have any more on the
specifics of the calls is the united
states government now in the business
of trying to discourage people or
governments from facilitating
people having me meeting with human
rights activists i don't
know this is not this is not a universal
position of the united states this is an
individual
who has been accused of three uh felony
charges
this is not a unique he's been accused
do you remember the old line that we're
supposed to all know
uh
people who are accused of crimes and are
allowed to
their right of free speech are they not
matt i think we've we've gone around a
legitimate question i mean you talk
about even in russia
that journalists have been persecuted
and political
activists have been persecuted and you
call for free speech around the world
but you're
not saying that mr snowden has the
right of free speech that's not at all
what i was saying we believe of course
broadly in free speech our concern here
was that this was there was obvious
facilitation
by the russians in this case uh we've
conveyed that
we've conveyed our concerns so you're
upset you're not upset about the press
conference you're upset that the
russians facilitated we certainly are
upset that there was a platform
for an individual what is that but what
does that matter really i mean
you know people that are in jail or on
trial in the united states
they give press conferences or they
speak out all the time i mean
it's it sounds to me like what you're
not really upset with
the act that he spoke you're upset with
the fact that the russians did something
on his behalf i think i've expressed
what i've said about
and you keep saying what we're upset
about but i think i've made clear what
we're upset about
i'm sorry question on this um the
secretary has said in the past that this
issue with ed snowden is just not his
portfolio and that all of this is being
handled primarily
through the justice department can you
clarify what the state department's role
is then because obviously there is
contact today
on the ground in russia with well i
think just for contact's sake for
everybody
that was said after a meeting with
foreign minister lavrov obviously there
are a number of issues
that we do discuss and we'll continue to
discuss with the russians but we're
going to express
concerns where we have them we have been
in touch on the ground
embassy officials have been in touch on
the ground with russian officials so yes
of course
we have expressed our concerns and they
have been expressed previously
but the secretary was making that
comment in the context of
his meeting with foreign minister lavrov
so what is the regular
uh channel communication between embassy
officials or
is it at a higher level i mean has
deputy secretary burns been in more
regular contact
we haven't really heard in recent i just
don't have any other specific
calls or contacts to read out for you
obviously there are many
components of the government who are
engaged and involved
in this issue but beyond that i don't
have anything specific
is it this building's uh role then to
formally request
a denial of asylum i mean what
what is the communication here if the
issue of him being fugitive is handled
through justice
what is it that state is doing well we
would like to see him return to the
united states
and he can be put on a plane to do
exactly that so does that mean the
issuance of an actual
letter from the state department would
the
counselor issue a letter on state
department letterhead
or is that simply reserved for the
attorney general that's ahead of where
the process is right now
um i've i think you know as events
unfold we'll we can provide you all
updates
on this point that you were talking
about just now
there was apparently a fresh offer for
asylum if he stops leaking that was made
today
which i understand that was made today
like a couple hours ago
so what is exactly your position i
didn't understand it so you did you tell
the russians that that is rejected
that is unacceptable what language did
you use well we've
conveyed outside of that i don't have
any independent confirmation of what's
been offered or what's been
approved or accepted uh beyond that
uh russia has the ability to do the
right thing the opportunity to
do the right thing and facilitate
facilitate his return to the united
states and
the second you said that he's not a
whistleblower he's a
felon now i think he's been accused he's
been accused
of felony yeah but apparently you know
public
opinion polls in america show that three
to one the public
says that he's a whistleblower does that
factor in like the petition in egypt in
any way
i think you're linking a lot of things
together there i'm conveying
he is a united states citizen he's
facing crimes in the united states
he can return to the united states and
face the charges okay so public opinion
should not matter in this case
in this case that's what you're saying
in terms of defining legal his specific
uh
role i'm giving you a an overview of the
of the us government view
privately russians are telling you in
moscow or at the united nations or in
washington
about this offer
are they privately i just don't have any
updates on that for you guys that was
the last time before
today's contacts did anyone from this
building talk
with russian officials or have all of
the conversations
been strictly from the justice
department
uh well i think even secretary kerry
spoke briefly with foreign minister
lavrov about it when they last
met so obviously there have been
contacts at a range of levels i don't
have any
update for you on the last high level
contact from the building but it's fair
to say that
the state department just like other
administrative
administration departments where
appropriate have been very engaged we've
been working very closely with the
department of justice
as secretary as the secretary also said
but wouldn't it be logical to assume
that if the entree was made for
amnesty and human rights watch and
wikileaks and other people
to get into this transit zone that
the russian authorities would have had
some sort of heads up and would have
conceivably made some sort of
arrangements in order to get them
into an area where theoretically they're
not supposed to have access because
they're not quote in transit
and wouldn't the us have had more of
an alert before finding out from the
media today that this
event was going to happen well you are
correct
that this is an area only accessible
with the assistance of russian
authorities
beyond that we of course saw the
announcement
earlier this morning online or wherever
it was first made
but that was the first we learned of the
plans for this event
that in his meeting with these human
rights activists mr snowden
committed more violations of american
law
i don't think i was suggesting that matt
okay then i
that i just don't understand i think
this is an incredibly slippery slope
that you're going down here
that the us government is going down
here if you are
coming up and saying
to us that you're trying to prevent an
american citizen
albeit one who's been accused of of
serious crimes
from exercising his right to free speech
you don't you don't agree with that i
believe that what i've conveyed most
proactively here
is our concern about uh those who helped
facilitate
this event and make it into a propaganda
platform right
the proper propaganda platform
aside free speech covers propaganda last
time
i checked it covers a lot of things
and i don't see unless he somehow
violated u.s
law by speaking at this at the russian
the transit line at the russian airport
i don't see
why you would be disappointed in the
russians for one facilitating it but
also apparently from what it sounds like
try to discourage them
from uh from try to discourage this of
them from
allowing this event to take place to
take place at all
well matt this isn't hacking happening
clearly because we wouldn't be talking
about it
in a vacuum and this is an individual as
we all know who has been accused of
felony crimes in the united states
we've expressed strongly our desire to
have him returned
to face those charges uh this is all
applicable context but as you have also
said he is a u.s citizen he remains a
u.s citizen
and he enjoys certain rights as a u.s
citizen one of those rights
from your point of view is that he has
the right to come back and face trial
for the crimes he's becoming committed
but the rights that you're not talking
about are his right to free speech
his right to talk with whoever he wants
to freedom to assemble
i don't understand why those rights are
why you ignore those
and simply say that he has that he's
welcome to come back to the united
states to exercise his right to be tried
by a jury of his peers
why is that the only right that he gets
according to this administration i don't
think that's what my statement conveyed
has the u.s spoken she had
a contact with the russian ambassador
here
um to convey that message um i'd have to
check on
additional contacts um beyond what i
just stated okay is there a belief in
this building
that the russians are not dealing with
the us in good faith
regarding edward snowden i think our
belief
is is what i stated which is that they
still have the opportunity to do the
right thing
we are disappointed uh in their with
their role in facilitating
the events of this morning but we will
continue to convey that we'd like to see
him returned and
they can play a role in that i was just
going to ask
has the administration sent any
officials or any
people representing the administration
to this transit area in the moscow
airport to try and make contact with
snowden directly
not that i'm aware of how um if the
russians accept his
asylum how badly will this damage the
relationship is it is it
you know is this the most important
issue in the relationship with russia
right now
uh well i'm not going to rank them
obviously we work with
russia on a range of issues there's no
question
that as we've stated broadly with any
country that would have a role
in assisting him either in transit or in
a final
uh final place for him to live that that
would uh
raise concerns in our relationship uh
however we're not at that point yet
raise concerns or would it kind of
damage the
relationship well at least this hasn't
happened yet they still have the
opportunity to do the right thing and
return mr snowden to the united states
and
that's what our hope is but you don't
really think that's going to happen i
mean you're growing resigned to the idea
that
they're going to accept his asylum
position i'm not that's not at all what
i stated
i don't think do you know if the
secretary has any plans to talk to
lavrov
i mean yes i realize it's not
necessarily their
specific portfolios but now that it is a
diplomatic thing
i'm not even aware of a planned call
matt
can i ask the wikileaks statement that
edward soon put out
he accepted all extend offers of asylum
including the one from venezuela and
said that that relationship is now
formal that he's now an asylee um
but does the us recognize this and he
also said that
that would give him some kind of
international legal protections
and in that case as an asylee what kind
of implications would that have for the
us's continuing efforts to extradite
them
well it's not for the united states to
recognize um
our position and our message to every
uh government we've communicated with
has been the same which is that we'd
like to see him returned
to face the charges he's been accused of
i don't have any independent
confirmation of what's been offered
or accepted in any of these cases
are we done with snowden okay okay
that today's events have not changed the
us position
and has not changed his legal status
snowden's status
uh sir on the second uh not that i'm
aware of
and on the first absolutely it has not
changed our position
u.s india summit this seos forum was
part of the yesterday
was investing in india the united
us ibc us india visions council summit
yesterday 38 years of u.s india trade
and business relations where
these 542 member companies were there
my question is that uh now they are
turning to
rather investing in india but investing
in america
by the indian companies more than 11
billion dollars and created
over 100 000 jobs in the us question is
that uh
they are saying 94 billion only between
trade between the two countries but last
year they were talking about this will
reach to 500 billion dollars
so where is the problem what is the gap
where how
these two countries can follow it we're
talking so much trade and
financing and largest to financial
income
countries and moving forward and so much
has been going on
trade and investment and so forth so
what is the future of these two
countries as far as
moving forward well let me simply say
that obviously the fact that the uh